my lovely genius brain farts this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends you guys already know I've
been using better help for a very long
time and you should too mental health is
something that everybody should focus on
is super super important if you're
thinking about giving therapy a try
better help is a great option just fill
out a brief question there to get
matched with a licensed therapist a
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy you can get
you there visit betterhelp.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com genius
I feel like sometimes with me if I'm
looking about looking at looking at
myself when I was younger which I feel
like this is a very naive
um
perception that I had was whenever I did
something like that right to hurt
somebody that would try to hurt me or
bully me right yeah it was to make sure
that they learned a lesson so they
wouldn't again yeah in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of The Genius brain
podcast I'm your host David so how is
everybody doing today good blessings on
a Sunday this is your church for you
non-believers out there yeah I know um
we were talking about this thing on the
previous podcast which I was so curious
about which was like the the Chinese
rating system we so I've heard about
this a while back right but I never
looked up what gives you a good or bad
score in the rating system and I just
kind of browse over it right now yeah
and they said one of the things there's
bad driving
and like debt yeah yeah
like all Asian people like what the [__]
I got how are you gonna rape me then
because I'm saying this right now you
know like when that when that stereotype
was huge like oh Asian people can't
drive well you know for me it's not a
stereotype I'm a terrible driver like my
credit score would be so [__] bad I
can't like most people can multitask so
when they're driving they could you know
receive a text here and there do all
this other stuff can't do it like if I'm
driving most likely I'm not touching my
phone unless it's like hung up somewhere
and I'll do a quick video but I'll just
hit record and I'll just stare off this
way yeah because I can't I can't look at
something when I'm driving it [__] me
up yeah I have pretty bad
um
what do you call that Focus ADHD
whatever yeah yeah but then you ISO
hyper Focus I think after like uh I I
don't know what something clicked at me
when I turned 30 something where I I
became way more tuned to watching the
road I think the idea of like the status
of how many people actually die on the
road I was like oh [__] it's [__]
dangerous out there like I should be
more attentive to this like something
when I turned 30 uh
my dad always said too it's like you
know you're driving you're literally
driving something that could kill people
yeah it's a missile it's a [__]
missile dude yeah it's it's pretty
[__] gnarly especially when I I
remember I used to say this phrase until
this actually happened and look don't
[__] judge me I was really young but
every time there would be traffic
somewhere like in L.A I just get pissed
I'm like dude somebody better be [__]
dead on the road and I would drive by
and then somebody died I'm like I will
never say this again and I feel terrible
oh [__] dude I I forgot to say this part
on the last podcast about our on on the
way to Palm Springs so last time I was
talking about we were trying to get to
Palm Springs Airport it was the only
airport going to Seattle out of Southern
California
and on the way there that was [__]
traffic right what could be worse but
thank God we left like five hours early
and then we got to this point where
there's this one car pulled over
um and
there was literally a body like wrapped
in a carpet it was wrapped in a not even
like a blanket it was like rolled up
carpet with feet sticking out like it
was white and then the guy in the car
looked super distraught it looked like
he was calling 9-1-1 and Dan and I saw
that like oh my [__] that might have
been my first dead body I've seen it was
literally yeah a couple days before
Christmas I saw so when I was doing this
walk in past in South pass I was looking
at and I was walking across the overpath
uh over path overpass yeah overpass and
there was a motorcycle that got hit that
was dead and you could see it like we're
watching the whole thing happen and then
you see them wrap up the body and stuff
yeah and no I'm sorry the body wasn't
wrapped at that point they were trying
to resuscitate the guy oh yeah and the
guy was fairly large overweight dude
yeah it was like on a Harley and they
were just compressing his chest trying
to get him back alive but he was dead
dude speaking of like CPR uh NFL a
couple weeks ago Demar Hamlin
dude was
did you you heard about this this is the
guy yeah
um it was Bills versus Bengals
um
uh someone with the ball ran with the
Bengals and then dropped his shoulder
because he was about to get tackled
Demar Hanlon has his arms like this
about to wrap him for the tackle guy
drops his shoulder and goes directly
into his chest right and they boom and
they both fall right
and so Demar handling gets up and then
he kind of wobbles and [__] just
collapses backwards yeah and then people
are like oh [__] and they called in and
the trainers ran out and then
the video's so [__] crazy
because they're asking the Bills players
to form a circles to hide it from you
know [__] 80 000 people watching and
then the millions at home and I guess
they were doing CPR on him on the field
because his heart stopped from the
impact right yeah and
um it was it's so [__] wild they did
it for nine minutes and then they
[__] brought him back to life crazy
so crazy so the what happened apparently
is like this rare event that they a lot
of Pediatricians know about right
because millions of kids Across America
play sports
and there's a thing that happens like
when they get hit in the chest like with
a baseball or playing football
like there's a millisecond a perfect
millisecond with to the tune of your
heartbeat right it's like a blip and
then the big blip and then a smaller one
right if it hits that last one right on
time it will [__] up your heart uh
pumping system it basically it doesn't
go boom boom it goes blah blah blah blah
blah right so your blood's not pumping
it's just going back and forth oh [__]
yeah so that's what happened to him
that's so his brain didn't get oxygen
because the blood's not flowing and he
passed out then his heart was just
stopped
right and when I heard about that
condition it made me think about my
friend back in ninth grade I told you
about
my friend Sean that's what happened to
him at a Taekwondo tournament he got
kicked in the chest
then he walked off and then he just fell
fell and then like yeah he was in like
yeah the ER and like
it was like just like Tamar Hamlet said
he didn't make it yeah you know out of
the hospital
and I was like wow like it brought some
kind of closure because of how long we
were like wow how did that happen yeah
and then now I'm like okay yeah when
that explanation came about I mean it
gave a lot of flood of memories about
him again yeah but also that yeah this
was
yeah just a I'm not gonna call it a
freak accident like because this is a
thing that could happen it was just that
timing yeah of it was just so deadly
yeah it's such a when I saw that
during this time that the same thing
that happened or not the same thing but
the event that happened at
simultaneously was Dana White slapping
the [__] out of his wife and so right so
holy [__] New Year's Eve New Year's was
like all this crazy news dude Dana White
kind of got lucky because his news of
him slapping his wife got buried under
that piece yeah and it was people were
talking about this too and like you know
we had this on a previous podcast but
they were talking about like we wonder
if Dana White did that as promotion for
the new slash for the new slap League
dude so it's trash yeah dude that's a
trash so people are kind of like second
guessing it yeah they're saying oh I
don't think he actually actually hit
each other they just kind of staged it
because how fortunate is that somebody
actually recorded this and put it up put
it up I mean the timing of it is is like
insane like he's like the way Dana White
explained to himself is like there's no
good timing or bad timing you know this
[__] just happened yeah right and so but
he has to continue with his life and
part of his life is this slappily yeah
yeah I understand and the irony but I'm
going to keep going at it so you see UFC
Instagram they keep posting that slap
[__] it's on my YouTube all over the
place the comments are like this is
trash we don't want this yeah and then
the other comments is Dana versus Anne
White that's super funny Dana versus ny2
people are so back and forth about
whether it was like Justified or not and
it was always the second slap that kind
of put the nail in the car yeah yeah
because at first it was like okay it was
self-defense or it was like a knee
reaction to him being slapped yeah and
he didn't go any further it was slap for
slap they're good they talked about it
fine but it was a slap and then I was
like oh he's winding up for another one
oh no no no no no no no and then the
takedown
but we talked about how on the internet
everybody is now saying
you know if a girl puts their hands on
you it's per you could do whatever you
want which I just thought dangerous I
just can't agree with that only because
Okay so we've had this conversation too
like specifically when you talk about
Combat Sports right
with with the Fallon Fox situation so if
you guys don't know who found foxes
found the fox is a transgendered uh
woman is a woman yeah transgender woman
right yeah
um who didn't disclose that uh she used
to be a man and she was cracking women's
skulls beating the [__] out of him and
beating the [__] out and there was a
time that she lost but you know if you
look at that fight it's because Fallon
Fox was not a good fighter but as a
woman she dominated dominated the [__]
out of people unless you've met another
woman who was her size but skill wise 10
times better so the skills had her win
the fight yeah
but the issue behind that was I said the
reason why you I don't understand the
argument of a woman hits you it's all
it's a free-for-all is because those
same people or just people in general
will say well when you talk about
transgender Sports you don't want that
because they have such a strong
advantage in in combat or strength yeah
just bone density everything else right
testosterone so in my in my opinion um
that I feel is like well how would that
make sense over here then right if you
know for a fact that you could destroy
this woman at any cost right you're
twice the size of this girl and she puts
her hands on you I'm not saying that
there shouldn't be consequences right
like yeah her doing that led to this
happening I understand that if you're
asking me if I would do that I probably
wouldn't I would just walk away or run
away yeah because at this point what's
what's the point she's going to walk
around and tell people oh I beat up yeah
yeah cool all right like cool [__]
story
like I don't I just don't find the
purpose in doing that unless your life
is in danger yeah it doesn't serve it
doesn't even serve your ego yeah to have
to beat up a woman I don't know how that
makes you feel better that's what I'm
saying like why it's so dangerous
because I feel like there is a
there is a handful of men out there who
think that way I feel like what they're
really thinking in the back of their
head is I can't wait for a woman to put
their hands on me so I can just be
justified in beating the [__] out of a
woman yeah that's all I hear that's what
gets you [__] horny guy yeah but I
saw this video
um which you know I listen I watched a
lot of five videos it's like it's like
my oh yeah my street fight stuff on
Reddit well there's this guy I don't
know what the context of this video clip
is right but this this white woman walks
out it was a it's a it's another uh like
black American dude
as white American Girl she comes out and
she goes you [__] hit my friend and
he goes what and he [__] decks her
dude oh and in the comments below
they're like stupid you know play stupid
games and win stupid prizes but I'm like
wait how is that justified at all and
they go well you see when she came up
she confronted him she should have known
that she was gonna get socked
listen I understand that you have to be
responsible for your actions but to say
that that was a Justified reaction to
somebody saying you hit my friend and
then you get knocked out it's a very odd
thing and they're like well you know
women want equal rights I'm like I don't
know
if that's what we're talking about I've
heard that right they call it equal
rights and equal lefts yeah I've seen
that comment yeah Lao as hilariously
heinous it is it's like I just don't
stand with it you know what does it do
what is the end goal it's like if unless
your life is in danger yeah unless your
life is in danger if the person's like
swinging at you and then you shove them
and then you get them out the way you
hold them down
or let's even say like I don't know if
they're swinging at you full force and
you don't know what to do when you clock
them I I understand to a certain extent
it's like a natural reaction right
because I have seen people be in those
situations where these girls are
swinging at them and they've shut them
to the floor and the girl acts like a
victim I've seen it at clubs I've seen
that bar it's like oh my God he [__]
hit me I'm like well you were swinging
on the guy and he shoved you away yeah
you fell I've been on the other end of
that man that's right I'm just sucked up
by you know an ex in front of my
favorite bar in front of all my friends
you know and all I said there was not a
thought in me like oh
[Music]
I mean honestly I was just like stop
yeah
I've been with somebody who swung at me
and that was a very tail sign of like
I mean this is a weird conversation to
have but I'm I wonder if like other
people have felt this too where
you can be with somebody who sometimes
puts you and puts you in a situation
that you don't want to be in and makes
you into a person that you would never
thought you would be yeah and there are
people whether it's guy or girl that
will bring this terrible side out of you
right that you never even knew existed
so the one time
I was with somebody that swung at me and
they weren't trying to swing at me in a
you know like a cutesy fun way they
missed me and they hit my arm and I had
like a little tiny little bruise but I
remember I stopped and I looked at her
and I was like hey
so either you gotta leave or I gotta
leave and they just didn't they're like
well what's the problem blah blah like
you're scared like about like a little
girl hit you and I'm like you don't
understand
I'm so [__] mad right now I looked at
you like you were a man you know because
you like it was defense mechanism yeah
so the I looked at you like you were a
guy for a split second which means that
if I look at you like a guy and you try
to Sock me in my [__] mouth I
actually thought about hitting you yeah
and it made me feel terrible so I left
yeah I gotta get out of here so what was
it again for personal experience like I
didn't get socked and then I was like
okay guess what time to let's [__] go
yeah I was like oh you're turning me
into a bad per I gotta leave and
eventually it was the conversation of
like listen being with you makes me into
the worst version of myself the idea
that I saw you as another male attacking
me for one Split Second for like half a
second scares me I guess it'd be like
you had self-control yeah that's why I
see like if if you're a bigger dude and
like this a smaller woman like hits you
and you like [__] Blaster to the Moon
you know like what how does how do you
feel fulfilled in that how do you feel
Justified how do you feel like a good
thing happened at all I feel like
sometimes with me if I'm looking about
looking at looking at myself when I was
younger which I feel like this is a very
naive
um
perception that I had was
whenever I did something like that right
to hurt somebody that would try to hurt
me or bully me right yeah it was to make
sure that they learned a lesson so they
wouldn't do it again yeah right which I
don't know if that ever worked right
probably invited them to yeah yeah and I
feel like for a girl that would do that
or a guy
um they're not going to learn from that
lesson they're just gonna do it again
and you would think that they would make
somebody think twice but people who have
terrible terrible toxic habits that
never teaches them [__] they'll just do
it again and try to get it like a one-up
again it's like oh I lost this fight I'm
gonna try it again next time yikes you
know yikes so yeah I mean like if it
seems like just like a very primitive
Savage idea of thinking it's just like
we are in a place where you can just sit
and think especially knowing like you
are not in immediate danger I mean
obviously you're getting hit by by
somebody but then understanding that
unless you're literally getting clocked
out and you're in fear for your life
like
because it's not like some I mean is it
your ego and pride like somebody's gonna
come up to him say hey dude I saw you
[__] run away from that little girl
all right it's like then that guy's a
piece of [__] exactly you know like not
you don't have to be like why do you
have to impress the guys that say Oh
that girl hits you hit her back hit her
back dude one time in a high school this
is a true story I was uh walking down
the hall and I was going to the bathroom
in June High School junior high yeah I
used to go to the school called James
Rutter and um right next to my geometry
class was the special ed class and I was
walking through the bathroom
and I hear screaming
right yeah and I [__] you [__] not
to me it felt like time slowed down
right because I see this person
screaming at me just with their hands up
and it was one of the special ed kids
yeah and I remember in that Split Second
moment all I thought to myself was okay
David you're going to be known as the
guy who got either got beat up by a
[__] kid yeah or you're gonna be
known as the guy that beat the [__] out
of her Target yeah like either situation
I [__] lose you lose so I just
remember like what the [__] should I do
because this [__] was big right
and all I could think about was I'm
gonna look like an [__] I just
remember this it's like a split I mean
it's no that happens in in those moments
like that's a scientific thing where
time slows down for people who have an
adrenaline yeah so like it felt like
this moment and I'm like okay David
you're gonna be known as the guy that
punched the [__] kid yeah
powered up
one of the um AIDS came up mentally
challenged not [__] excuse me
mentally mentally but this is what you
said in junior high in the early 2000s
so luckily one of the aides comes up and
grabs him yeah and I just remember this
relief coming over me because I'm like
I'm gonna be [__] branded for life oh
my god the guy that just sucked up a
mentally challenged kid because I got so
scared dude in my art class in high
school
like
um there was yeah a mentally challenged
kid special a kid um who was there I
mean it's art class
and I guess a group of guys like at a
table were telling him hey
Ed called you [__] he called you
[__] and I'm minding my own business
in my class like I'm I'm tracing slam
dunk comic books you know
and then he comes up to me he goes hey
call me [__] and I was like what no
he goes you and me
three o'clock at the flagpole okay I'll
see you there what the [__] and I was
like oh [__] yeah like what no I didn't
I didn't do that and it's like you and
me three o'clock oh my God and I didn't
show up obviously I'm not trying to go
to a fight but I had to like see him
later like dude I I didn't do it and
then those [__] [__] were like
yeah I did yeah he did he called you it
I was like no man you [__] kids man
these are evil that's [__] crazy yeah
Joe told the story where uh one time he
was uh
there's two I have two funny stories
about this
same thing happened to him in class
where it was something along the lines
of like
somebody there was a kid behind him that
was like making Asian jokes like Chinese
jokes and stuff and so Ed turned around
and he [__] sucks this kid in the
mouth and the kid starts welling up in
tears and he runs out the classroom and
goes to the special ed Club
I had a cousin too where this was so
[__] embarrassing
this Cousin of Mine by the way is
literally the biggest [__] up ever right
and in our family he's known as the [__]
up he's doing a lot better now but
better in the sense of it's good enough
for him yeah everything else he does
he's so [__] obnoxious but his
girlfriend came crying to me once uh
tell you uh at the time and she was so
embarrassed like what happened she was
well because we went to the same
Community College at the time this fool
there was a person behind him that was
just like screaming and making noises
right and they were they were in the
commissary eating lunch
and this person's just like moaning
super [__] loud and he turns around
in the morning he goes would you shut
the [__] up turns around as a kid in a
wheelchair that's mentally challenged
and he's just going oh no oh he told his
kid to shut the [__] up oh my God and so
she he looks he doesn't even apologize
he just grabs the books and walks out
and then adults are there and she left
leaves her there and she's crying like
she's so embarrassed oh my this
[__] is insane dude this is the
same [__] guy who and it's funny
because we have uh mutual friends and my
mutual friends know him yeah and he's
done a lot of stupid [__] in his life
and I guess he's like cleaning up and
when I tell him like oh look yeah he's
doing better now like he's graduated and
every time I tell people that he went to
college people were like who what
college Harvard Community yeah what what
[__] College accepted him I'm like I
don't know but he's graduating he has a
degree and he my friend told me the
story he goes this guy was so [__]
dumb I remember going to community
college with him he would write the
answers to the test on the top of his
hat the bill
we obviously get caught like what the
[__] are you talking about dude man holy
[__] there's certain people in your
family that's so [__] embarrassing
like you just never want them to know
yeah that they're related this was the
guy that um I told the story of the
podcast word
during
um
he he basically wrote down on on a
Facebook post that I like I'm terrible
to him like on Facebook that all that
I'm like Mr Hollywood big shot but is he
the one that asks you to be his best man
no no this is a [__] okay and so
he writes this whole post about oh like
I gave David money uh I helped him out
when he was super down and out I'm like
you're poor than me I slept on my couch
this type of [__] and I'm like I've
never taken money from you because
you're so poor it's like what are you
talking about dude what is this delusion
yeah and so you know obviously people
who don't know me they're writing in the
post like oh that's [__] up like you
know these are Mysteries Mr Hollywood
and then then there's other people on
the bottom of the post who are my
friends are mutual for like that doesn't
sound like David I was like and they're
like you shouldn't be posting this stuff
like isn't here a cousin like what the
[__] are you doing so I start calling
this fool up
and I'm going off on him right and he's
not picking up his [__] phone which
which is making me more Angry yeah and
then I call his mom my aunt and I'm like
tell your stupid ass [__] son to pick
up his goddamn form and [__] kill him
right she's like what happened I was
like look what do you put up on Facebook
and she sees it she starts calling him
he doesn't pick up and he just goes yeah
because he's scared now he's not gonna
[__] this fool up and he finally calls
me back he's crying right like oh I'm
just like I'm just going through a bunch
of stuff I don't give a [__] what you're
going through like I'm your family dude
what the [__] are you talking about and
why are you making [__] up and I got so
[__] mad and this is so funny because
I yelled at him because we're having
crisp the Thanksgiving is coming up and
I'm like Thanksgiving is at your house
don't [__] come on come to his own
house I'm so [__] mad at him do
people go through some weird [__] man I
mean it's because it's
um main character syndrome right and if
you're the main character then you're
obviously the good guy right then if
that's the case
then nothing should be your fault it's
other people's problems and then people
create enemies people create their
antagonists their opposite you know
their Nemesis like I get that too like
from people I'm like yo I don't I don't
have any beef they like we're not even
any competition or whatever like what
did I do to you yeah yeah right like I
you know random [__] dance there's a
guy
who who who like wrote his hate mail on
on my posts it was super random about me
being a fake Christian and all that [__]
I mean I could have just said I'm not
even a Christian yeah but anyway I just
kept ignoring him so I was like okay
what the [__] is up with this guy and
then I realized he messaged me like last
year like oh hey Edward I um I've been
going through a lot of tough stuff
through my faith I hope I have a lot of
questions to ask if you can reach out to
me that would mean a lot right and I
didn't reach out and then so after that
it just changed to vitriol oh no that's
happened to me a lot right so when
someone goes through a problem or
something yeah like and they're going
through [__] and you don't even know
them like I have no connection to them
or whatever somehow like in their
loneliness man they create these enemies
and that's you you become the target
yeah I don't know where that comes about
but it's just a lot of people who lack
introspection this podcast is brought to
you by better help my friends if you're
not working on your mental health you
should be doing it now because it is
super super important I have been
working on my mental health for years
now and it has helped me so much and if
you think about it if you're working on
your physical health your mental health
is just as important so when you're at
your best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down and
you may feel overwhelmed or like you're
not showing up in the way that you want
to working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
not using better help for a long time
has helped me out a lot because I have a
therapist basically on my phone or at my
fingertips the accessibility is what I
love about betterhelp the most and also
it's a lot more affordable than
in-person therapy if you're thinking
about giving therapy a try better help
is a great option it's convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhealth.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help help.com genius dude
some people like specifically with this
relative I every time I think that this
person is doing better they always show
that you're still a piece of [__]
[__] right and you know it took me a lot
of like analyzing with him right and I
specifically believe with him it's like
the way his father used to talk to him
my uncle like this was the this was the
uncle that literally would wake us up
and call us [__] yeah like like
that's how he goes good morning retards
and I'm like dog yeah why like why would
you talk what's up Lazy Dog you know do
all this other [__]
and useless yeah and you know he has
like middle child syndrome and
everything else like that but one of the
habits that he picked up I think because
he was spoken to so poorly when he was
younger albeit a lot of it was deserved
for him because he was a [__] idiot
probably who still is now I don't know
let's not say that he's better yeah but
he had this habit of
and I'm not sure if anybody out there
knows people like this where
every conversation that you have with
them is him trying to prove his worth
you know so we can't have a normal
conversation talking about our lives
it's almost like hey did you see what I
did did you see what I did yeah I did
this I did that oh I'm doing this and
I'm just like nobody cares and I
remember his older brother one time just
uh taking him aside and going hey you
got to stop this like
I just want you to be happy yeah like I
don't care like you keep talking about
all these accolades about what you're
going to do what you are doing nobody
cares like take those successes and
these wins that you have and just either
keep it to yourself share with people
that like understand like you don't need
to do this every time we're together and
when he was going through a lot of
financial troubles like when we would
meet up I gotta remember his dad like
was super sad
because he bought him all these great
Christmas gifts and then he looked at
his son he was like hey
I know you're not doing well you you
don't need to buy this stuff like I
don't care about these things but he's
always like vying for somebody's
attention and approval approval because
he doesn't have self-worth and now that
he's doing better he's now projecting it
in a negative way so for example he
proved you guys all wrong exactly that's
what he did yeah and so I I part of me
wanted to because somebody sent me this
everybody sends me these posts about him
because there's a lot of people who
dislike him yeah right because of how
many times he has [__] up in in poor
Faith right and has screwed up so many
things with all the people that were
really good to him that they don't mess
with me do you see what this guy wrote
I'm like what did he write so he writes
this post about how like oh I've
graduated now I had this degree I'm
successful people told me I shouldn't do
it I was like nobody said that
nobody [__] said ain't character
syndrome exactly nobody ever said that
and then he starts posting how much he
makes now on a public post yeah how much
he makes and how much he wouldn't have
made if he didn't have this degree all
this other stuff like the more the story
is when people don't believe in you
believe in yourself you need a private
Journal bro yeah yeah nobody said that
yeah literally no and people are like
laughing they're like okay and you have
you know people write like yo you're my
hero like I you know these people who
are also idiots yeah yeah but then
everybody else who really knows them
they go oh and he wrote this post I
think the part of the post that upset me
the most he goes when people don't
believe in you they say you can't do it
I was like no no no let's write how it
really was you have [__] over
everybody who is kind to you who is
important to you who have showed you and
give shown you great like Grace and love
and you have screwed these people so
much that they stopped caring because
you hurt them so much that's the honesty
so the post should have been hey I
[__] up now let me prove to you that
I'm a better person instead it's nobody
believed in me and now look at me I'm
successful instead of the fact that you
[__] up so bad you stepped on
everybody along the way and then finally
you became so after you burned all your
Bridges it's a narcissist's affirmation
that's what it is I mean I I am just now
listening to this I just finished a
podcast it's called the rise and fall of
Mars Hill
um because I was uh somewhat vicariously
involved because I was like deep into
their Ministry like well their podcasts
and stuff
and um that Pastor there like he has
massive narcissistic personality
disorder but he's a pastor you know and
for all the fuck-ups he'd done as a
Christian like repentance is a daily
thing this guy like refuses to repent
for the abuses he does is this the guy
that he looks he's like the pastor that
looks super cool and he has like his
dick no no that's the hill song okay
yeah yeah this guy's answering
this guy's name is like Mark Driscoll or
whatever but I know all about that like
because there's a thing a lot of pastors
do like especially narcissistic ones
they have this origin story you have to
create an origin story of where you came
from and your origin story is a lot
better if you didn't have help your
origin story is much better if you were
down and out and nobody believed it you
know so like
um his story would change over and over
again like I used to be a youth pastor
at a mega church didn't like the mega
church system so I started my own then
he's like I was never part of ministry
tree I never went to church and ever
went to Seminary but I just felt like
God called me to start a church great
origin story then it just changes like
yeah we started from nothing to this
nothing to this that's a narcissistic
thick affirmation can you see that a lot
so that's great that there's a
terminology for this because we talked
about this a lot you know where you know
we knew somebody who you know she had a
habit of doing this like if if there was
something that somebody went through to
the car you I went through that too it's
like did you really you know I mean like
I can't even I can't even have my own
trauma yeah I can't even have that yeah
it's like oh my dad died he's like yeah
well both my dads are dead yeah
you know it's like the weirdest Joe told
this funny story too where um there was
somebody that we knew where he's he's a
little odd right the very talented
person but there was a time where they
had like this pow-wow yeah and I know
this person too where you just kind of
let them talk about their delusions
because
so they expose themselves yeah
and then what and then what and we just
keep doing it so his stories would get
crazier and crazier and crazier so
Barton Barton Joe would tell their
personal stories right and this like
mutual friend of ours where you know
Barn Joe had been through a lot of [__]
yeah I mean especially specifically you
know this area that they grew up in
during that time was not very good and
so
he would tell they would tell their
stories right and then this [__]
who is clearly a dweeb not that's not a
problem yeah but you know me being a
dweeb myself like I only I can only
Regale a majority of my gangster stories
are not my personal experiences like
what I saw Around Me growing up yeah
right it's not me going out with the gun
shooting people or whatever because
that's honestly what it was you don't
have to insert yourself in these stories
and say that was you and like I was the
one with the gun yeah you could just
tell the story like how it was told to
you or what you saw yeah but Bart and
Joe are really good storytellers and
they would tell stuff I'm like oh [__]
that's pretty [__] nuts and all of a
sudden you hear this one [__] on
the side trip it's like yeah I went
through that stuff too and it's like
that happened to me once yeah and so
specifically a story that he told out of
[__] nowhere he was telling the story
about how
he got it too
a fight trying to protect this girl and
I'm like okay this kid has never been to
a fight in his life right
and that's a good thing it's not a great
thing to fight people right yeah like
it's if it's especially when it's not
necessary yeah and so Barton Joe were
telling these like very interesting
stories and he goes yeah I remember when
I had to protect this girl that I really
loved and then like I have my this when
I first realized I had I had two
different sides to me right and he said
let's say it was like there's Bill and
then there's Bob right and like okay and
at this point we're just like yeah what
else what else it's like yeah so when
Bob gets out it's crazy right and he
said that he woke he went to this guy's
house and then next thing you know he
woke up and there was blood everywhere
oh my God
vicarious like cringe right now and
everybody in this room is just like hot
what the [__] are you talking about
besides one person and I remember
because Joe doesn't really
that he's not going to listen to this
[__] right and he's just like dude stop
[__] lying this is so awkward right
and then you know his like to somebody
at the time in this group was just like
oh why are you so mean to him right like
don't be so mean like this story could
be true but obviously after they spent
more time with it like okay this guy's a
[__] nut bag yeah right but that was
like could you imagine having to sit
there and listen to this ridiculously
heinous story right like I understand
there are certain stories that seem so
unbelievable that but there's like still
like a modicum of truth that makes you
latch onto it yeah but this idea that
you created this split personality and
then you woke up there was blood
everywhere you had a bat next to you and
I'm like where else is the story going
to go yeah and this guy by the way like
if you shove them in his chest his
[__] it would collapse it's just
concave it would just collapse right and
I've seen him in like weird tough
situations where he just freaks the [__]
out yeah like I've literally seen this
guy cry in front of me over [__] so
I'm like okay why do you do this and
this is like one stories out of many
yeah right why are you there's
pathological liar he like for example
like I remember I would tell people like
I took Taekwondo when I was a kid so my
kicks were pretty good and I remember
like I showed somebody this clip and the
people didn't believe me I was like no I
was pretty [__] good at it yeah and
then at like 300 pounds I was doing
spinning heel kicks I actually have
videos of it and they're like oh [__] I
was like yeah I told you I was I could
do this yeah yeah and so this guy chimes
in he goes oh I was like a Taekwondo
black belt too which Taekwondo black
belts at the time everybody was getting
them but the specific one that I got was
from a guy from Korea and he was an
[__] yeah yeah like you were not
getting a black belt at all so I only
got up to a red belt stripe yeah I
didn't have a black belt
um but when we would go to these
competitions we would [__] wipe the
floor with everybody because of how
severe the training was yeah and so you
know wanted this kid to show us his
stuff and I'm like you have never ever
kicked before
like a hundred percent UFM you maybe
have baby taken a couple of classes but
you could tell when somebody has done
kicks right because Taekwondo is all
kicks we had no punches besides like the
boom says
and so I watching him do this I'm like
Doc you even lied about this like why
why do you lie about these things man
what is the point but this person can't
stop doing it though like if they have
to why do they have to make up their
experiences right why can't you just go
out there and experience it yeah or like
if you heard the story from somebody
else just tell the story yeah yeah yeah
I mean like for me in this podcast I
always have to change things because for
anonymity anonymity right so there's a
lot of like
things I have to switch out right
because I early on in this when I was
doing like YouTube you know people felt
a certain way because I'm from a small
town so I was like okay I'll change up
like 30 of the story this guy named
Daryl Kim yeah
[Laughter]
I didn't give a [__] yeah yeah but then
you know you matured you start being a
little more empathetic and I'm like okay
I don't have to say the name and I could
switch like certain details up even to
the point where there will be like
stories where someone comes up are you
talking about me I'm like no it wasn't
about you I was like did you go through
that
oh [__] oh you should get your pass too
fast
but yeah you meet these people and it's
it's very odd like I don't know what
they're going through I I think just a
clear lack of guidance in there it could
be like when narcissists get depressed
and their disassociations and their
Daydreams just become about how [__]
awesome they are when their reality
isn't so awesome yeah it was like that
guy was like the Dementors you know he's
Michael Scott yeah you know I mean um
honestly it's like misguided people
perhaps they need a hobby but honestly
like if you want a story to tell if you
need an experience like ask some cops
you know to give you a ride you know
take a ride with them Shadow them or
something like there are ways to
experience [__] try something you've
never done before let yourself get
[__] up and you gotta and have the
courage and the confidence to be like
talk about how much you [__] up and
you know what that's a great story
we have so many stories about how much
we [__] up and they're hilarious dude
you own it there's some people too who
don't go with these crazy experiences
and they still tell great stories like
Steve Green cracks cracks me up because
Stephen I remember one time ago there's
an episode of JK news we're talking
about oh we used to get our ass beat as
kids and he's like dude man for when I
was a kid my mom used to say I love you
she used to come and ask me yeah like it
was [__] tough out here but you know
there's ways to be interesting without
you having the trauma boss it's the
level of self-awareness and discernment
over your own life yeah you know just be
[__] real you don't have to lie to
kick it it's like you're already hanging
out with him it's like why do you have
to keep trying to impress us more you
know it could be the idea of like they
see you on a pedestal they need to get
on your level and they're trying to
prove themselves to you typically
because like I've experienced it too
like in childhood they're they're told
that they're useless that they're not
enough and that they're they're
worthless and they'll never amount to
anything but it's like you can prove
your parents wrong but like don't don't
protect that trauma onto your friends
yeah you know it's like their
self-awareness is really hard too
because even with the relative that I
know I think like me looking back and
seeing
kind of and his father actually asked
him to come to the house not too long
ago and apologize to him because I think
he started to see the negative effects
that he had on him yeah uh as an adult
yeah right him you know coming for
Christmas and trying to buy all these
gifts even though he's not financially
stable yet and it's just him vying for
his like dad's attention and approval
all the time like let's see I'm not dumb
see I am better because he was a pretty
big [__] up and he was like a [__] up in
the sense of he would find trouble that
didn't have to necessarily be he would
look for trouble all the time like he
moved into a nicer area like the whole
area is like full of rich white people
and then all of a sudden he's like
finding him so he goes oh I'll hang out
with this [__] I was like did
you drive that far to hang out with
these guys like how did you even meet
these people like they're my
neighborhood yeah and I'm avoiding these
humans mentioned that earlier a
commuting gangster yeah
okay so with the commute yeah I got a 45
minute commute to gang bang homie I
represent this set just takes a while to
get there yeah it was it was a very odd
thing and like watching his dad
apologize I think like uh allowed for
him to start like that healing process a
little bit which got him up to a certain
point and then I remember I was talking
to my mom about him and she goes you
know with him like
I was like oh he's doing super well I'm
like uh yeah he's doing better you know
I told him like your guys's perception
of him is very interesting because you
still look at him as that little baby
you know he's that little kid and for me
I see him as an equal yeah as as my
equal so when I see him [__] up and I
see him do the things that he does and
say the things that he says it's not
it's not for me it's like oh look at
this poor child I'm like this guy is
trying to [__] up my life yeah you know
and he he and I used to hang out all the
time like we used to kick it 24 [__]
seven yeah but as you get older and you
start to realize like the people that
you were around because uh out of like
Comfort or accessibility aren't
necessarily the best people to be around
yeah I mean it's like because his family
exactly right and then when you grow
older like you do have to realize like
the level of boundaries you need to
create for yourself even with family
yeah and we have like no nothing in
common yeah we can't talk about things
we have nothing in common so our
conversations are super [__] dull
because if I'm saying like if he asked
me like what am I doing or what am I up
to I already know where the conversation
is going to go it's going to be like oh
well this is what I'm doing God Jesus
Christ man who [__] cares dude I grew
up around a lot of weird people too we
also had a mutual friend who um was very
very sensitive and guess let me tell you
something being sensitive my family is
not a good look yeah like you'll get
eaten up and so
this was actually a uh so I understand I
tend to we joke around really hard right
um not even hard as some other people
I've met but we joke around a lot right
but this was a friend of mine who ended
up being a pretty popular YouTuber
doesn't do YouTube anymore yeah but
we're both from Sacramento and then
we're we're meeting up for Thanksgiving
so our family families all got together
so a lot of like I'm pretty sure people
who immigrate who don't have a lot of
family here a lot of like the other
immigrated families yeah they call each
other cousins and family because we
don't have anybody else yeah I've got
I've got a cousin family in North
Hollywood right but they're not we're
not blood related exactly so there was
these three or four families that would
meet up and so he's successful on
YouTube so am I
or meeting up and he would start his
videos like this
here we go
well hey guys I didn't see you there
right and I was joking around and I'm
like hey dude you know with your video
so he goes how the [__] did you not see
people then when you set up the camera
you [__] idiot you know you're
obviously just Rose I'm roasting him
right and I'm like that's the dumbest
[__] thing I've ever seen him and
we're I'm roasting and people are
cracking up this will guess up and he
leaves damn he leaves the house he
doesn't come back I'm like
what the [__] man and then so you know
it's like their YouTube is their
identity exactly and so I was a little
confused he goes oh that was a little
harsh I was like bro that was a soft
soft yeah I just made fun of how you
introded your videos you can make fun of
my videos my videos are stupid as [__]
yeah so I don't understand what the
problem is but then
he's just very very sensitive yeah yeah
and till this day hyper hypersensitive
he's one of those guys that you can't
say anything like negative bad around
him or he takes it super personally
which kind of sucked for him because of
how we grew up like I remember
um like
his older brother my cousin's older
brother he once pinned me to the floor
and socked my arms yeah until they died
yeah yeah they were like numb like down
to the bones exactly and listen I
deserved it I was doing some [__]
[__] you know but I'm a little shaky
yeah you know I don't know man
with
with them to I think like social media
kind of exacerbated their bad habits
right right made them a little more
sensitive made them feel a certain way
when other people were successful one of
the things that a lot of social media
stars have to go through right now that
I've been seeing is a lot of resentment
towards other people who are successful
yeah right yeah they go oh man like all
My Views are dying or you know I'm not
popping as I used to be or these other
people but it's like dog listen
I've had this conversation with somebody
where I said hey you should be grateful
that you had x amount of years of
success on the top yeah right most
people don't even survive that long
there are people now like now I forgot
what I was reading which made sense
because I said on this podcast before
it's like the longevity of a social
media stars like averaging two to three
years now damn that's like worse than
NFL yeah you have been able to travel
the world yeah hang out with people you
were hooking up with a bunch of girls
sold out crowds for [__] like 10
years yeah and you made a great living
off of it
what you didn't do was do great things
with your money so you're more or less
upset at yourself not anything else like
yeah you don't you don't have the money
and the success and the thing that you
thought you were gonna be because you
squandered all them [__] like you
can't blame the new generation of
YouTube viewers you can't gen like blame
the algorithm perhaps you can but like
you know like I think people need to
have a better grasp of themselves and
their identity because their identity is
tied down to their success yeah and one
of the things too that I saw for a lot
of people and you know like early
YouTube musicians right
they were very very successful in the
beginning because there was no
competition yeah the competition's rough
now there's so many talented people out
there yeah and so they're finding out oh
like oh your music is nostalgic but it's
not as good as these other peoples which
was true like there was a specific
rapper that I really really don't like a
YouTube rapper and this one gets no
[__] views and back then he was
popping yeah and I never understood why
like I never got it right and this guy
lost his [__] mind he's out there I
don't know what the [__] he's doing but
he's also one of those salty
[__] too right where they're
just out here just cursing the name of
other people who are successful I was
like listen dude if you did what you did
back then now it still wouldn't pop off
right you got very very [__] lucky
yeah well people got smarter and a
little bit wiser right even and that's
just content now people it people's
tastes change all the time I think I'm
very fortunate because I've had like the
same fans since ever yeah you know and
they've been [__] with me for a very
long time like of course like you know
30 000 views per video isn't like 200
000 to 400 000 I used to get back in the
day but the content's different and time
has changed so like
I think if you're on social media one
thing that you guys do have to realize
that you have to evolve because think
about this too like do you like your TV
shows every season being the same
something new happens yeah something
changes people have kids
um people grow up look at the friend's
Dynamic bosses together with with uh
[__] uh Rachel they break up Rachel
find somebody else Monica ends up with
Chandler if everything stayed the same
you wouldn't [__] tune in and people
also want to script their lives on
social media too though right so when
you talk about evolving and changing
they're like oh that means in my social
media life you'll see me have a
girlfriend you'll see me get engaged
you'll see me get married you see me
have a kid it's like as if you know
that's just the typical way social media
is supposed to go bro sometimes I see
people I'm like did you just have a kid
because your views are dying
I'm like just like oh your family
Channel's not doing well did you pop out
another kid because you need more views
oh no that's a little weird yeah you
know and you could kind of sense it too
it's like um this seems very odd you
know I have a kid to save this channel
yeah yeah not my marriage bro man
there's certain people that I see like
online like I don't know these guys
personally but it's just like damn you
tell by exploiting your [__] kids
this is an exploitation of your [__]
children yeah where they're now addicted
to being online and social media people
they're begging to be in front of the
camera like you're creating a [__]
monster man I feel like we're gonna see
a new type of child star right the the
social media star you know that they
grow up under some [__] and then you
just see them grow up on social media
too and it just becomes like trash
material like it's like it's a weird
thing with our society where it's as if
we sacrifice our celebrities we see
their come up and then now we must
sacrifice them yeah yeah we must see
them come down so we must lift up the
new and improved celebrity well that's
why that whole when we're talking about
the whole Chinese like social ranking
thing yeah it's such a shitty idea
because of what people are already doing
right so we already have technically a
social ranking thing and that's called
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter right
because everybody puts up their their
best foot forward and you never get to
see what they actually are that whole
social ranking thing if you bring it to
the states it's just going to cause
people to be more dishonest and fake do
the consequences yeah of losing points
and your score being low like you can't
get a loan like you can't get a job get
a job yeah like they basically like
where they place you in jobs because
your social ranking system because you
have to pretend to be something that
you're not and I know some people might
think well wouldn't it cost people to be
better people if you're a piece of [__]
you're a piece of [__] yeah right it's
going to take more than a ranking system
to change that ask anyone that grew up
in church so many fake people who put up
a front about their [__] Holiness
yeah and their piety and their [__]
perfect life yeah when the idea of a
church is supposed to be like hey come
here because this is a hospital for the
[__] up yeah 100 except people love
showing up to the hospital perfectly
cured and like okay and be like no I
need to be here you know and I never
care about I wouldn't say never but I
definitely care less about what somebody
pretends to be in the front right I'd
rather have somebody be honest like if
the ranking system allows people to be a
little more honest and then they have to
deal with consequences that way it makes
more sense for me right because
I don't like people who pretend to be
nice yeah I'd rather have somebody be a
piece of [__] and I know who you are so
I can navigate around you yeah
accordingly it's a million times worse
to be [__] deceived by a two-faced
[__] a hundred percent man and
so like that's what that ranking system
will do and you'll see that in that
black mirror episode yeah where she's
trying so hard to create this image of
what a perfect human being is her real
self doesn't come out what she cares
about what she feels until the end of
the episode holy [__] that means
everybody that walks out of their door
in China has to put up a [__] mask
every single person that's too much dude
you want to talk about a mental health
crisis yeah like for you not to express
how you feel to to say what you want
um obviously within like a modicum of
respect yeah but because you're so
scared of you not being able to make a
living and to to be a part of society
dog I would lose my mind my rank right
now for sure would be a zero point
something damn well do you know how to
get points I guess like if you help the
elderly and treat them right so it's
right it's just like seeing those Elders
at church that just like oh
and then they just like are super nice
to you and some [__] [__] but
they really don't give a [__] it creates
a fake Society yeah I I don't want to
live like that dude it's already fake
enough as it is yeah it's already so
difficult navigating this world right
now specifically because of Instagram
and everything else where
um I know a lot of young people who kind
of
they
I think their life is [__] because they
look at what other people have right
it's like your life is fine man yeah
like your life is perfectly fine and all
those people out there that put up like
the best post dude I wish let me tell
you you guys make me a [__]
millionaire
watch it's I'm gonna [__] call
everybody out yeah it's like oh really
you're a happy little family
um how about this you know what I mean
yeah because they're trying to sell
products you know which I don't really
agree with like like this I just don't
think it's a the end goal isn't great
right and like some of the most
miserable miserable people I know
show some of the best posts ever yeah
here with my family it's like that's so
[__] funny I think I thought I saw
you suck your [__] you know husband
in the mouth the other day damn like oh
[__] that's crazy but again I ain't no
snitch and plus everybody gets their
justices at the end and it's happened
already so yeah it's what it is
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast uh you can
catch Ed at edpark VP and then uh Bible
study at Momos is his podcast where you
can go and check that out uh leave in
the comments below of any other subject
she wants to talk about and then we'll
see you all next time
[Music]
right now